Let's get started with
the Udacity student data.
We'll start with the data
wrangling phase.
That is, acquiring and
cleaning the data and
you'll pose a question once you know
what data you have to work with.
Data acquisition can happen
in a variety of ways.
In this case,
you acquired the data by downloading
some files that were available.
In other cases, you might need
to get the data from an API or
you might need to scrape
it from a web page.
You'll also often need to combine
data from multiple different formats.
Now don't worry if some of these
terms are unfamiliar to you.
They'll be covered in more depth in our
data wrangling course which is linked in
the instructor notes.
It's a great course if you'd like to
learn more about how to get data from
a variety of different sources.
Your files are in a format called CSV
which stands for comma separated values.
A CSV file is similar to
a spreadsheet with no formulas.
The CSV format is also very
easy to process using code.
Unlike, for example, and XLSX file,
which is the format used
by Microsoft Excel.
For example,
let's take a look at one of your files,
which contains student enrollments.
Here's what the file looks
like in Google spreadsheets.
There is a row for each time
a student enrolls and columns for
different pieces of information such as
the account key, the enrollment date,
and the cancellation date, if any.
Now here is what the file looks like
if you open it in a plain text editor.
A plain text editor is
a program like Notepad or
Sublime that shows exactly
what is present in the file.
As you can see, the actual contents
of the file are very simple.
The header row from the spreadsheet
is present as the first line
of the CSV file.
The second row of the spreadsheet is
the second line of the CSV and so on.
Within each row, you'll see
the first cell, followed by a comma,
followed by the second cell,
followed by a comma, and so on.
This makes CSV's very easy to process in
programming languages such as Python.